congratulations you got three shows on
the top three
bmf um power book two power book three
what was your reaction when you first
heard that news
well i heard it in a uh it was supposed
to be confidential yeah uh
we had they brought us together stars
but let's all be on the call and kind of
go over what was for
for force
and when they showing the deck and i
said i said hold on i screened each
that is the only reason why you know
that we have the top three shows in
african-american latino households i'm
going
why would you not like for stars yeah
did not make have a press release or
have anything go out
you have to top three shows
in this in this place
my question is do they not want to have
the top three shows
in the household
is it is it because
time the time period
that and i mean my overall deal is up so
they probably don't want to make me look
as
exciting as i am at the present moment
because
i've taken off to a point that they
because it will cost them it should cost
them more
yeah yesterday's price is not today's
first
i love that for you oh my god okay so
fans are excited about powerbook four
they're already saying it's going to be
the best one yet how does force compare
to the rest
i think force the intensity of power
initially
you come straight into that because
tommy was on that level with ghost in
the very beginning he was like his his
man his partner the entire time like
when you get into
as the ghost
series
starts to take off it i i was concerned
about that one because
it was it was going back with the
intensity like we went back into him
going to college and hustling there is
it
it brought on new viewers that were
millennials that they watched the show
from their telephone
instead of we're seeing a spike in that
when the storyline shifted but when
i and i'm glad we didn't lose them like
that
there was enough there but when you get
ready the organic spin-off to power is
really forced because the the next
spin-up was raising kanan and that took
you back to the 90s and it was like
defining why my character was so bad in
the beginning
so yeah get a chance to go on that whole
journey with them but
forces this is power's true continuation
what happens with tommy and look if you
in a nutshell power is
a story about drug dealer makes it to
the top of the drug trade who
says
because there's no old folks home for
drug dealers he's saying could i have
done this a different way because i
success and
it's difficult to do it to navigate the
streets
for him to be able to make peace i could
have made it any kind of way and
the woman that was the right woman for
you on the journey is now the wrong
woman because she's seeing you as you
are
yeah that's how you got here but you're
looking at her like she only sees me
like this and i'm this because it's the
old folk home for drug dealers it's just
attention you're looking at it going i'm
gonna be sitting in the penitentiary
and she can't see it
you know what i mean so this
leads him to go
be with someone who knew him from before
he was that
who doesn't know him as
the person he developed into and
and that just happens to be
the
district attorney and everything that's
that's when the tv moment see in doing
that
that point when you make it and you're
doing so well that you think you could
have did it a different way
all successful drug dealers reached that
point
this is where they identify with why the
story is the way
and
there's a
a point where you start going
even if you don't you don't do anything
and and you connect it to him
on uh his personal side he said why you
know
you get your hair done why you don't get
a beauty salon
why you don't do it here take the money
get the beauties along wow because
now we can put the car in it
you see what i'm saying like that starts
to happen you start to be
interested in traditional business
because
you financially can't do anything with
the money that you have without that
without having the connections you know
i mean so yeah it starts to happen on
different levels and this is why the
beauty salon and the laundromat and the
different things that you saw the
nightclub
empower
with things that they are come in
contact with yeah you know so it's
universal that that works but when you
get to tommy going to chicago it's like
the the
even the the theme song the approach
the big thing is chicago yeah i want to
use chicago like we use new york city
and
you know no new york there's someone
who's representation of everyone here
chicago the tones
it's a little different in chicago
lifestyle the stuff that they're doing
out there so
you want to feel that lifestyle come
into the actual project yeah
initially i'm looking trying to think
about how to create the theme song i get
a little dirk he's the biggest thing out
of chicago at the present moment yeah i
i come with jeremiah he
vocally
is one of those guys and out of chicago
yeah
jeremiah can sing on anything and sound
good yes and one of the guys that is
underrated
on that level because you know what he
did doesn't make the music videos he
doesn't match up
you don't see him as an artist as good
of a as an artist he is like sometimes
you hear the music and go oh that's him
oh okay but he repeatedly asked that
writer just yeah two years so even with
some other people singing he wrote it
yeah i mean like that guy
that's why i always i work with him i
keep keep him close because he's good
yeah the the fans don't play about the
theme songs like they they don't play so
do you ever i know you don't feel pr i
don't feel like you feel pressure in
life
but
i just don't see it i don't see it for
you king but i have to ask like when
you're making the theme song are you are
you approaching it differently are you a
little apprehensive at all
you know i looked at it like okay it has
to feel
like chicago when when you're doing that
there's a yeah i'm like i got to listen
to things too
to find that yeah and they're saying
well i start with it and then production
wise when we get the track because
actually jeremiah's producer mm-hmm
produce the record because i'm like yo
nah i gotta feel like this we worked on
it until we got to the right place but
then
once i feel like now we got something
like
like i sent it off i'm gonna come back
and dirt vocals
like when you hear vocally yeah
television show
has the same words
but my delivery is different
and that's because it has to be a song i
wanted to feel like when you listen to
it
you listen to to a record that just
feels good yeah
i'm this way he's that way and and it's
just a collage
to the actual record like you know so
it's to say i said the exact same words
in a different tone to match up with
everything else so you you would feel
like a real song
yeah any celebrity cameos in this and if
not is there anyone you would love to
have on the show
well no celebrity cameos right away we
did
did you know what's interesting is
the shows have taken
develop their own little style of doing
things so yeah
so look
raising kanan is turning to like the
actors show
yeah you got uh patina millers she's the
tony award winning actress playing uh
makai
mom yeah and you've got
all my apps you got like like
omar they don't talk about omar as much
as they should because he's a superstar
in my book like i watch this stuff for a
long time but um
away from that you got joey badass he
just he went to oscar for
a short film and then that's his
long-form performance right there yeah
so it's becoming a cool spot to put like
strong actors
and then
the the other theme
the cool place to put like we have
moments
in power like with kindred mm-hmm like
popping in we make sure that if we bring
them
it's not it's not like just show your
face at the bodega you're the guy at the
counter
you know what i'm saying like
you know do that where we just
water things down to the point that
nothing means anything you know
the significance and being able to come
to bring him out he hasn't been out
since uh
since eight mile
um
like before they can get him back in
front of the camera wow
me directing
the series is what got him there to
actually come out you know
we had to digitally remove his beard
and take him back down to when he was
19. yeah oh like we used the same uh
technology they used to the irishman
that's dope
yeah it was a real quick scene yeah
but it was
cool because it was in detroit
you know and was playing white boy rick
for me at that point
so it was exciting then
the way you look at bringing
like the cameos or bringing someone into
the project i try to
make it as
relevant to the project as possible like
the a little more
you know
because if you just we can we can really
stop like we can really just bring
everybody into it like come on
they let us say come on
no squat
well it's always a pleasure to talk to
you congratulations on everything i
can't believe that was ten minutes
let me just keep going
what the hell anyway you have a great
day it's good to see you
you